Indians have been voting today in the
third and biggest phase of the countries
more than month-long general elections
voters electing a new Parliament and
Prime Minister Narendra Modi from the
ruling Hindu nationalist BJP is seeking
a second term his main challenger is
leader of the Opposition Congress party
Rahul Gandhi the election is the world's
biggest with 900 million voters in total
eligible to vote they have to elect 543
representative to the lower house of
parliament called the Lok Sabha one of
the issues that has been set to stage in
these elections is the issue of
unemployment the ruling BJP is accused
of suppressing a government report that
claims unemployment is at a forty five
year high this even as the economy
expands
it's a strange paradox that's affecting
millions of India's youth dwu
correspondent nimisha jaiswal travelled
to the state of Jharkhand in the
country's East to find out more morena
Patil scored the highest grades in his
undergraduate degree in sociology he
received a gold medal from the president
of india for excelling in his
postgraduate studies he went on to get a
third degree which allows him to become
a teacher he's one of the most qualified
young men in his small village of took
to KO in the eastern state of Jharkhand
yet the range has been unemployed for
two years it's difficult to sit at home
after studying so much in the village -
I hear chimes that despite my
qualifications I'm useless there's no
work in the village the government is
paying no attention to this there's no
advantage in earning a degree it's a
piece of paper lying at home and
betangel isn't alone other graduate
students like him are applying for every
job opening that comes up however
overqualified they may be but they say
there are no vacancies seasonal farming
is the main source of livelihood in the
region employment opportunities are few
and far between locals here tell us that
as a result many young men migrate to
big Indian cities like Delhi and Mumbai
and some even go abroad to countries
like the U
we Afghanistan and Malaysia but shark
hunt isn't the only place where young
people are in trouble every year
millions join the workforce in India
according to unreleased government data
unemployment is at a 45 year high
critics say that while the governing BJP
is rhetoric has focused on nationalism
in this election it has been silent on
job creation
a coalition of youth groups called the
young India Rights Committee has come
together expressly to campaign against
the Modi government they say they will
support any candidates who stand against
the BJP and its policies on education
and employment several member groups are
left leaning this meeting is in support
of a candidate from the CPI ml a
communist parties have been very very
horrible for the youth of India there
has been a very dangerous structure
shift you know during Modi regime when
it comes to the youth and the students
of the country the youth is the future
of the country and they are not only
fighting for themselves those are
fighting for India where you know right
to education right to implement right to
health and rights of the citizen young
locals attending the meeting are just as
angry the government needs to ensure
that young people are provided with
secure jobs so they don't have to
struggle to earn their livelihoods I've
been looking for a government job for
three or four years but no luck yet and
being education a student I am also a
very upset from the government system
because government has lost the system
but they haven't know any people on how
to provide that this system to the
door-to-door to the rural areas a
student
even as night sets in the crowd listens
on with rapt attention the message here
is clear a vote against Modi is a vote
for their future